[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis ni cinévores absolue moi je même
en ce moment a en ce moment c'est un peu
plus dur je vous cache pas vrai dans
deux mois je me rattraperai voilà que
madame pécresse
elle voudrait que des gens qui ont
bracelet destiné à éviter la prison on
les enferme dans des préfabriqués elle
en donne d'ailleurs la marque elle dit
algecos zahia karcher et alger qu on
fait deux fois la pub votre inconscience
a parlé mais non pas du tout moi mais
pas du tout dans dawn élu président
pense pas qu'on va tout de suite au
cinéma c'est pas annoncé l'association
d'idées canon je vais pas penser que
j'irai au cinéma j'ai pensé que quand
j'aurai quand je serai à la présidence
de la république j'aurai à nouveau la
maîtrise de mon emploi du temps macron
c'est la france déprime et bien moi je
veux la france des salaires parce que la
france déprime sa déprime je ne suis pas
du tout sans liking de l'extrême j'ai
dit je ne veux pas aux femmes d'une
époque pour le dit arrêtez arrêtez les
programmes sur sa liste quand vous
voulez mais franchement la parcourt le
dit parler des francs mais non je parle
des français de coeur la station et
essence c'est le seul endroit où quand
vous prenez un pistolet vous vous faite
braquer cette campagne est très moche
elle est très très moche pour tout le
monde c'est une campagne vulgaire
violente une campagne dans laquelle il
ya beaucoup de bruit à sa place
j'arrêterai les mots cinglants de
ségolène royal sur la candidature dany
d'algos selon elle la mère de paris
englué dans les sondages doit jeter
l'épongé
à gauche le vote utile
arithmétiquement et devant bien sûr
changer d'ici le dépôt officiel des
candidatures et la tâte nuit mais pour
l'instant le veau qui fait le candidat
de gauche qui est devant c'est à dire
fait jean luc mélenchon il a apprécié le
soutien de ségolène royal il lui a dit
sur les réseaux sociaux sur twitter je
remercie ségolène royal pour ces mots de
rassemblement à l'égard de ma
candidature son mérite est d'autant plus
respectable car je sais que son soutien
n'est pas un ralliement c'est dommage de
ne pas être dans la fidélité à une
famille qui lui a quand même tout donner
moi je choisis la fidélité y compris
dans la difficulté je sais pas si c'est
la bonne boussole noyal en fait quelques
jours elle disait qu'elle pouvait
soutenir valérie pécresse il ya cinq ans
l'a soutenu dès le premier tour emmanuel
macron j'imagine ségolène royal avec un
t-shirt a soumis dans le dos et jean
dans le gros le vote utile ça n'existe
pas le vote c'est sacré et le vote c'est
le vote utile c'est le vote sincère soit
utile c'est une camisole de force mais
je crois que c'est jean luc mélenchon
qui a déjà 10 à marine le pen et cartes
où poussent vers la sortie
successivement toutes les personnalités
et tous ceux qui incarnent des
sensibilités c'est vous qui partez
marion maréchal et quelques années la
bête toujours eu le droit à la parole il
a été considéré par marine le pen et le
rn il a toujours pu exprimer ses
opinions je pense qu'il n'a pas été
malheureux c'est son deuxième mandat de
député européen je rappelle à 15000
euros par mois ça relève plus du
fonctionnement d'une secte que ce que
que du fonctionnement d'un parti
politique mature et je le dis avec une
certaine gravité vous allez c'est pas
une décision facile moi je me suis
engagé quand j'avais 14 ans la manière
dont ces gens pas sur la forme
d'ailleurs tant sur la forme que sur le
fond je le répète en disent beaucoup
plus sur eux que sur nous c'est pas une
secte mais en tout cas c'est un
fonctionnement qui a des dérives un peu
sectaire oui parce que voilà qu'ils
forment d'emprise celle-ci sentiment
d'avoir bien vous libérer deux gérants
rien j'accueille les bras ouverts
nicolas bay comme tous ceux qui veulent
me rejoindre et je ne fait pas le tri
entre ceux qui viennent des seins et
ceux qui viennent des autres
oui je sais pas
je envie
mais après on va tendre était
passablement miloudi il faut